nature has not made us good at chess we
completely suck at chess yeah um
in fact that's why we designed it as a
game is to be challenging
and if there is something that you know
recent progress in chess and go
has made us realize is that humans are
really terrible at those things like
really bad you know there was a story
right before alphago that uh
uh you know the best go player thought
there were maybe two or three stones
behind you know an ideal player that
they would call god
uh in fact no they're like nine or ten
stones behind i mean we're just bad
so we're not good at and it's because we
have limited uh working memory we're not
very good at like doing this tree
exploration that you know computers are
much better
uh doing than we are but we are much
better at learning differentiable models
of the world
i mean i say differentiable in a kind of
you know i should say
not differentiable in the sense that you
know we run back for up to it but in the
sense that
uh our brain has some mechanism for
estimating gradients uh of some kind
yeah and that's what you know makes us
efficient so if you have an agent
that consists of
a a model of the world which you know in
the human brain is basically the entire
front half of your brain
um
an objective function
which
uh in huma in in humans is a combination
of two things there is your sort of
intrinsic motivation module which is in
the basal ganglia you know what the bits
of your brain that's the thing that
measures pain and hunger and things like
that like immediate
uh
feelings and emotions um and then there
is
you know the equivalent of what people
in refreshment call a critic which is a
sort of module that predicts ahead what
the outcome
of a uh
of a situation will be and so it's it's
not a cost function but it's sort of not
an objective function but it's sort of a
you know trained predictor of the
ultimate objective function and that
also is differentiable and so if all of
this is differentiable your cost
function your your critic your
uh
you know your your world model then you
can use
gradient-based type methods to do
planning to the reasoning to do learning
uh you know to do all the things that
would like an intelligent agent
to do
and the gradient-based learning
like what's your intuition that's
probably at the core of what can solve
intelligence so you don't need
like a
logic based reasoning uh in your view i
don't know how to make logic based
reasoning compatible with uh efficient
learning yeah and
okay i mean there is a big question
perhaps a philosophical question i mean
it's not that philosophical but uh that
we can ask is is that you know all the
learning uh algorithms we know from
engineering and computer science
proceed by optimizing some objective
function
yeah right
uh so one question we may ask is uh
is does learning in the brain minimize
an objective function
it could be a
you know a composite of multiple
objective functions but it's still an
objective function
uh second if it does optimize an
does it do does it do it by
some sort of gradient estimation
you know it doesn't need to be back prop
but you know some way of estimating the
gradient in efficient manner
whose complexity is on the same order of
magnitude as you know actually running
the
inference
uh
because you can't afford to do things
like you know perturbing a weight in
your brain to figure out what the effect
is and then sort of uh you know you can
do sort of estimating gradient by
perturbation it's it to me it seems very
imp implausible that the brain uses some
sort of
you know zeroth order black box
gradient-free optimization
because it's so much less efficient than
gradient optimization so it has to have
a way of estimating gradients
is it possible that some kind of logic
based reasoning emerges in pockets
as a useful like you said if the brain
is an objective function maybe it's a
mechanism for creating objective
functions
it's it's a mechanism for
creating knowledge bases for example
that can then be queried like maybe it's
like an efficient representation of
knowledge that's learned in a
gradient-based way or something like
that well so i think there is a lot of
different types of uh intelligence so
first of all i think the type of logical
reasoning that we think about um that we
are
you know maybe stemming from
you know sort of classical ai of the
1970s and 80s
i think humans use that relatively
rarely
and are not particularly good at it but
we judge each other based on our ability
to uh
solve those rare problems it's called an
iq test i think so like i'm i'm not very
good at chess
yes i'm judging you this whole time
because
well we we actually with your with your
uh you know heritage i'm sure you're
good at chess
no stereotypes not all stereotypes are
true
well i'm terrible at chess so um
you know but i think perhaps uh another
type of intelligence that i have is this
uh
uh you know ability of sort of building
models of the world from
uh you know
reasoning obvious obviously but also
also data
uh and those those models generally are
more kind of analogical right so it's
it's uh it's reasoning by simulation
and by analogy
where you use one model to apply to a
new situation even though you've never
seen that situation you can sort of um
connect it to a situation you've
encountered before
uh and and your reasoning is more
you know akin to some sort of internal
simulation so you you're kind of
stimulating what's happening when you're
building i don't know a box out of wood
or something right you can't imagine in
advance like what would be the result of
you know cutting the wood in this
particular way are you going to use you
know screws on nails or whatever
when you are interacting with someone
you also have a model of that person and
and sort of interact with that person
you know having this model in mind uh to
kind of
uh tell the person what you think is
useful to them so
i think this this ability to construct
most of the world is
basically the essence the essence of
intelligence
and the ability to use it then to
plan
actions that will
fulfill a particular criterion
of course is is necessary as well
you